This is the correct equation. If you got it, excellent work. If I don't drive
the car anywhere or drive it for zero hours, I still have to pay $5. That's my
registration fee. For driving it one hour, I pay ten more dollars. So I have to
add ten to five, to get 15. Two hours would $25 and three hours would cost $35,
and so on. So when x is zero, we get a y value of 5. That makes sense for this
equation. When x is 1, we get a y value of 15. That also makes sense. This 5 is
the fixed or constant part of renting the car. Anyone would have to pay this.
The variable part of renting the car is the 10 times x, since you spend $10 for
each hour that you drive the car. We know the cost of the car depends on the
number of hours, x.